welcome to this video playing mr. Boris
from Lou came i played this guy before
and 12 times ok i'm tom it's a twin stem
the decline ok let's take care while
night xt5 recently got popular due to
the efforts of chronic very interesting
way to play taking with the night but he
went for the classical approach yeah
night eh fry this is a very very decent
line for black let's see if I can
remember anything I think you should
take and play long castles yeah well
very often in those positions they play
g4 but I never I'm never really
convinced that this is such a great idea
oh it feels like in it's also damned
some source of counter play let's see
the town Knight f3 maybe Bishop g4
okay I'll prepare that age 393 to ya
bishop at five but maybe here
hmm
yeah probably i didn't played in the
most precise manner if this exchange is
possible like shouldn't have any any
problems okay maybe I should play 444
opening the center it's possible that he
castles long of course the same type of
position is some notoriously solid for
both sides the pawn chains are rather
rigid with F 2 e 3 d 4 against p 7c 65
and okay many here he went for short
castles which is of course possible if I
was more concerned about long castling
but not a problem of course so should I
play if I am come on I am f rocks rd 1
and e 1 and term probably I should open
up the position for the rooks
of course it's not on b6 is controlling
d5 so this is some a well-placed piece
hmm night-night c4 might be an idea
let's let's do that
Queen a five he needs to be he must
reckon with Bishop f5 and then he can
take with the Queen I thought Bishop
takes Knight takes rook e5 okay if I go
mmm takes Bishop takes Knight X as a
tempo but also very weakening
I wonder if if if I should try to get to
the dark squares Quincy one to h6 this
kind of idea yeah this is that is a good
idea actually I believe but not so easy
to accomplish rupee ADA's good wheels
okay I'll first take a pledge eHome
gaining some space and now see 22222 age
6 yeah come on let's let's do that he
can go night see father the temple but i
really only i want to go to h6 I mean
this does not help him he of course has
night e 6 to cover g5 as some 95 as a
threat okay him he covers that
beforehand even
if i go here i am i threatening 94 queen
somewhere 95 anyway because h7 is
hanging Fergal 94 let's check this 94
queen somewhere and 95
I can take once play 96 mmm okay let's
do this anyway but he needs to go to the
seventh rank I believe ok no 95 is
possible let's do that he needed to go
to the seventh rank I think I don't see
how a defense h7 now 27 was what I
thought it's necessary ok this is what
we'd be tricky any weight because I'm
down like one and a half a minute
position wise I really don't see how a
defense this besides critics g5 yes
check I don't know I hope I'm able to
immediately exploit his bed coordination
of pieces this would help tremendously
look here maybe and Queenie 5 i'm also
taking basabe this is helpful
check-check
check 20 time morning 20 seconds
now 20 seconds it's not much check check
check check check check check
games wrong I'm just too slow just too
slow ah yeah I really should have should
have made it her around here 15 seconds
yeah yeah not one of my fast fast days
okay well i think it was all it all
comes down to this position if he plays
a queen d 7 which i really expected
because you need to protect age 7 then
there's nothing special going on i think
at least i don't see any any great move
I mean I can play Johanna queen a fall
back or something but there's nothing
nothing special happening this just
straight away losers don't check
probably i have some some quick away
even but okay I mean it's a queen
against against two nights is really
can't completely you can and i don't
think i can put too much blame on myself
chest wise i could have played the
quicker of course to to make it but what
can you do okay thanks for watching